i am so fortunate to be a producer on
this show so i get to have a seat at
that table and get involved in
everything but sometimes everyone i work
with is like
why don't we just like try something
that you have never done before and i'm
like well that's new and so we have a
segment that's brand new called new to
drew
[Applause]
because sometimes you just have to let
go of the control and just fall back and
try something you've never done before
so today i get to try a sport called
street golfing that's right
and patrick barr aka tiger hood who made
headlines for bringing new york city
communities
together
with his pop-up street golf
tournaments please welcome tiger hood
thank you um i've been so excited and
looking forward to this um it was such a
pleasure to watch your videos maybe if
you could tell us how this all started
you know where did street golf like
originate for you it came out of nowhere
i found a golf club in a garbage can
and i started playing on the streets
the spirit moved you
yeah what compelled you to pick up that
golf club and do something with it i
always wanted to try it i always went to
try golfing just couldn't afford it
so
this was your entry that was my ticket
how was your ticket in yeah how do
communities react to what you're doing
what's the feedback
really good
yeah really good i had a couple of
complaints but it's been really nice
there's always some fussy person you
know that's that's life and people have
responded like
you've done videos with will smith
they just
rolled up one day and he started playing
i mean it's will smith
[Applause]
um what was that moment like for you a
tiny guy so down to earth it's
ridiculous he's just really cool he's
really cool um all right well um the
will smith challenge
that you did um sort of went from just
doing it with him and continued on will
you tell us what the will smith
challenge is
well i mean he did it in three swings so
if you can get it in three swings you
know it's like it's like the way i see
it is that
when you get the script you read the
script you know that's his first swing
the second swing he took was his stress
rehearsal and the third swing he took
was the performance of a lifetime
oh yeah so poetic and you saw his skill
set i mean you know he started what he
measures up and everything so he he does
play hi um
well
i'm i'm ready to uh to try this and i've
like i've never golfed i'm i i'm mini
golfed
okay
all right you can do this okay i'm
really excited all right i'm gonna take
the yellow one
that's my color
oh god
i'm already really nervous and uh is it
anything let me just have you take a
practice swing first if we actually hit
anything since we see how your form is
it's terrible
looking good so far
okay okay now when you turn when you
when when the club comes up yeah i wanna
like you're gonna pivot a little it's
going to bring your healer put my hip
into it
put my old hip into it i have the hips
hips of a german shepherd
thank you
well that was great
okay oh dear
oh god
you really know you are that middle-aged
woman when your wrist hurts i was like
ow
you can still beat them
better
thank you
for the ever
like i have like my inner billy madison
where i just want to like or no sorry um
happy gilmore trust me
it definitely helps
you got this
[Applause]
they don't get up and in that box
[Applause]
i mean i'm not just saying that because
i suck it's and it's not an excuse it's
hard to
get it up in the air
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
oh
you know what i'm just a woman who wants
closure
[Applause]
tiger looking good joey looking good
you try it looking good
[Applause]
you are the best
i i think
if we can speak in metaphors um
may we find something that brings us
together
may we try to
put a positive spin in someone's day so
thank you for everything that you
contribute to the city your photography
is so beautiful and if you go to our
website at the drewberrymore show.com
we're going to be featuring your
photography because that's another part
of this story we need to talk about it's
so beautiful thank you
um and before you leave we want to give
you a little token of our appreciation
we got you a brand new bag to carry your
golf clubs
oh no
oh my god wow
no way
oh my gosh
wow
thank you so much for teaching us how to
be in life let alone what to do oh thank
you drew thank you so much
i love you so much please go to our
website and check out patrick barr's
beautiful photography aka tiger hood
[Music]